[Music]
this is insane on this Wednesday night
the Wildfire smoke smothering parts of
Canada and the U.S I need to get a Mass
for something the action some hospitals
and airports have taken and what can
happen as Wildfire particles travel
farther
the Bank of Canada thinks the economy is
getting too hot so with hiked interest
rates again taking a bite out of
would-be home buyers that's kind of
infuriating to hear
a scientist accused of developing
Syria's chemical program is traced to
Alberta very sweet old man a global news
exclusive
and a wild Discovery in the wild the
crocodile who made herself pregnant
global national with Donna Friesen
reporting tonight
good evening and thanks for joining us
tens of millions of people in Canada and
the U.S are being urged to wear a mask
or stay inside as a massive body of
smoke swirls over the Northeast
Parliament Hale barely visible in this
drone shot of downtown
Ottawa as an eerie Haze hovers over the
capital for a second straight day
as of today there are
2293 wildfires that have occurred in
Canada approximately 3.8 million
hectares have been burned also as of
today an estimated 20
183 people remain evacuated from their
homes and communities
the situation on the ground remains
alarming with this country already on
track to exceed the largest total amount
of burned area ever recorded in a single
year we'll have more on the fire fight
in just a moment we begin with concerns
over historically bad air quality in
some of North America's biggest cities
tariya isri has our top story
thick Haze is coding much of the country
and choking the nation's capital at one
point the air quality in Ottawa was
worse than Delhi with pollution 15 times
above the World Health organization's
recommendations for what's considered
safe Public Health agencies are urging
people to stay inside but that's not
always possible smelly with the gas
burning and the smoke you just
constantly can't get a good
can't get fresh air in it
the unprecedented start to Canada's
Wildfire season is creating dangerous
conditions across North America this map
shows some of the worst spots in Ontario
and Quebec in Kingston the skyline is
not even visible while Toronto is
closing the Dome of the Roger Center for
Wednesday night's Blue Jays game it's
very very heavy it's so heavy Carlton
Place Hospital West of Ottawa canceled
some surgeries because of poor air
quality inside the operating room its
aging ventilation system can't filter
out all the smoke environmental
scientists say there's evidence to
suggest Wildfire particles become more
toxic as they travel the nature of of
particular air pollution is that it's
sort of a dynamic mixture we Define it
as sort of Airborne particles of a
certain size but within that size range
you know the composition can change the
change in climate is unleashing more
severe weather and creating a host of
health hazards so the constituents of
wild fire is not that much different
from cigarette smoke
the difference is that in with cigarette
smoke people smoke maybe six 12 times a
day
on the other hand we breathe 12 times to
20 times a minute
the exposure is especially dangerous if
you're pregnant a senior or have
respiratory issues with my asthma it
burns my throat and I itchy my throat's
itchy and then I cough so I have to have
my inhaler if you have to go outside
doctors say wear an n95 mask they helped
protect against covid-19 and now offer a
layer of defense against another threat
to Public Health
Global News Ottawa
[Music]
that smoke from Canada led to some
apocalyptic scenes in New York City
today dramatic drone shots show an
orange glow filling the sky
mid-afternoon as the thick Haze
triggered air pollution warnings across
large swaths of the U.S
similar scenes played out in several
Northeastern U.S cities with some
officials calling the worsening air
quality an emergency crisis Jackson
prosco joins us from Washington Jackson
how's it looking there
well me too here we are 800 kilometers
away from the source of the fires and
yet you can see the smoke in the air it
burns your eyes it tickles the back of
your throat and if you stay outside long
enough you will definitely feel the
impacts of it unprecedented is the best
way to describe the situation here right
now but I want to go back to what
happened in New York today as we saw
that thick plume of smoke really move
into the city effectively blocking out
the Sun and causing that apocalyptic
orange glow over the city you know
visibility was reduced so much that not
only did officials tell people to stay
indoors and limit their time outside
unless they were wearing masks but we
actually saw two of New York City's
airports limit departures and arrivals
they implemented ground stops because
visibility was so low and so bad and the
air quality index was classified as very
unhealthy for anybody hazardous to
anybody at over 400 that is
unprecedented that is historic in that
city right across the U.S we saw about 6
60 million people in places where the
air quality is classified as unhealthy
and there are ongoing warnings about
what the next few days are going to look
like because we're expecting to see wave
after wave after wave of this smoke blow
through these areas and really hamper
air quality and that's why with us
locked in this weather pattern there
continue to be These Warnings to really
limit your time outside here in
Washington D.C this morning we actually
saw air qualities drop into the very
unhealthy category this morning the air
quality index was around 200 but the
worst is yet to come over the next few
days and so local schools have actually
canceled recess canceled outdoor
activities and field trips and kept
students indoors because it's really
just too unsafe to have them outside for
prolonged periods and so for the next
few days there's going to be this
continued threat but nithu that's not
all there's really concern about the
possibility of localized forest fires
because this area is also in a drought
as well
right Jackson prosco in Washington
thanks Jackson
there are 414 fires burning in Canada
more than half are out of control around
21 000 people are out of their homes and
about 6 500 of them are from First
Nations communities on Vancouver Island
near Port Alberni the Cameron Bluffs
fire has grown and it's closed the only
major highway in and out of the area but
in Nova Scotia some good news the
Shelburne County Fire the largest in
that province's history is now being
held and not likely to spread but it is
still considered out of control there
are fires burning in almost every
Province and territory and much of the
country is at high risk for fires shown
here in red and orange
Quebec has about 150 fires there are
more people out of their homes residents
in two Northern Communities had to leave
last night and more evacuations are
possible in the days ahead Mike
Armstrong reports on the fire fight and
the help coming
firefighters in Quebec's North have been
overwhelmed only able to fight about a
third of the fires that are burning
when they weren't battling on the ground
was Northeast of shibugomo Tuesday winds
moved at about 20 kilometers closer to
Town
the mayor took to Facebook Tuesday night
to say the fire moved faster than
predicted and ordering an evacuation
people were told to gather as few
possessions as possible and move to
rabarval about 250 kilometers away
about 7 000 people tried to leave almost
together causing a bottleneck followed
by bumper-to-bumper traffic the rest of
the way what would normally be a
three-hour Drive turned into eight and
stretched through the night
the urban arena is now a shelter for
about a thousand evacuees others are
staying with family or friends or in
hotels Quebec now has more than 11
000 people who've been forced from their
homes that number is likely to grow
the case of the town of chapet there
were evacuations last week people went
home and they may soon be told to
evacuate again
the province has right now according to
the premier about 520 firefighters and
150 soldiers over the next week help is
coming from other provinces and other
countries New Brunswick France United
States Portugal Spain and Mexico so we
are looking to increase the number to
about 1200.
now there is an issue with aircraft
Quebec has 11 tankers in the air with
six more on the way but Pilots are
closing in on the maximum they can fly
they have mandatory rest coming and the
aircraft have mandatory maintenance and
checks every 50 hours we cannot expect
that all the aircraft will be able to
fly full time every day
now the extra bodies are good news but
they're only a short-term solution the
situation is bad enough Quebec's
firefighting agency says it's likely to
need help All Summer Long Mike Armstrong
Global News
to the affordability crisis now many
mortgage holders are in for more
financial pain the Bank of Canada raised
its key interest rate a quarter
percentage point to 4.75 percent the
highest since April 2001. interest rates
are working to slow inflation but the
Central Bank says they're not high
enough to bring it down to the two
percent Target in April inflation swung
up for the first time in 10 months
adding pressure to hike interest rates
today it's all having a real impact on
the way people approach home buying and
as Mike drolets the central bank and the
federal government are facing criticism
that they're out of touch with Canadians
Canadians working to catch up to
inflation in interest rates once again
saw everything come to a screeching halt
as yet another hike put more distance
between Kate McLaughlin and her dream of
owning a house that's kind of
infuriating to hear especially with the
cost of like grocery prices and
everything has gone up
um it's like there's just no grasp on
reality the 0.25 bump is equivalent to
180 a month on a million dollar mortgage
and that's on top of the four percent
hike since last year which Economist Jim
Stanford sees as confirmation the Bank
of Canada is fixated on inflation and
only inflation so the fact that
Canadians are experiencing a lot of pain
because of these interest rate hikes
doesn't stop the bank in fact did they
want to see more pain
in Ottawa there was no avoiding the
slings and arrows directed at the
liberal government so Justin
how do you expect people to pay their
bills now
leaving Deputy Prime Minister and
Finance Minister Christian Freeland to
essentially shrug her shoulders while
admitting there's widespread hardship
it's really hard and it is imposing real
pain on a lot of Canadians and Canadian
families
absolutely understand that but do they
because home ownership isn't in the
cards for an increasing number of
Canadians we'll use Toronto as an
example where the median household
income is eighty five thousand dollars
with a one hundred thousand dollar down
payment and fixed rate mortgage a family
can afford a four hundred and fourteen
thousand dollar home the average price
of a home near downtown is 1.3 million
moved to scarborowitz 1.2 amidst the
Farms of Ajax is roughly the same and
even further afield in Bowmanville is
pushing a million and you can't see the
city average just doesn't cut it anymore
you're looking at a mill apply just for
one level of that house another bonus
for McLaughlin with fewer people able to
buy rents just keep going up people are
now in a situation where they're never
gonna be able to
buy but they also can't afford their
rent leaving a for sale sign over the
Canadian dream
microlay Global News Toronto
[Music]
I'm Eric Sorensen at the Canadian open
with some news about the business of pro
golf that story ahead on global national
soccer Superstar Lionel Messi sent
shockwaves through the sport today
announcing his plans to make a major
move abroad Miami
he says he's made the decision to sign
with inter-miami CF and join Major
League Soccer leaving Europe for the
first time in his pro career Messi
reportedly turned down a more lucrative
offer from Saudi Arabia's pro soccer
league to move to the U.S
Saudi Arabia has used billions of
dollars from its Sovereign wealth fund
to quickly assert itself on the global
Sports stage including the saudi-backed
live golf tour which has agreed to a
surprise partnership with the PGA and
European tours four-time major Champion
Rory McIlroy one of the biggest critics
of live had mixed emotions to the news
I look at 10 years down the line you
know I think ultimately this is going to
be
um
it's going to be good for the the game
of professional golf I still hit live
like I hit live
Eric Sorensen reports from the Canadian
open which is being overshadowed by the
drama of the deal
it's set about golf you drive for show
but you putt for doe as the Canadian
open tees off this week the PGA the
European tour and the Saudi public
investment fund have putted to a deal
that should strike it rich for pro golf
I was pretty shocked that it happened
that quickly too
it's a huge climb down from the moral
arguments the PGA made when the
saudi-funded live golf tour was launched
luring big-name golfers with millions of
dollars in what many believed was a
blatant attempt by the Saudis to launder
their ruthless human rights record PGA
commissioner Jay Monahan suggested then
his golfers do what's right any player
that would ever consider leaving
have you ever had to apologize for being
a member of the PGA Tour but as lawsuits
flew both ways Monahan decided to do a
deal with Yasir Al ramayan lives sponsor
and now chairman of the new Pro Golf
entity how did we go from you know a a a
confrontation to now being partners
we just realized that we were better off
together
than we were fighting or apart golfers
like Canadian Mackenzie Hughes felt
blindsided right now it
obviously it's gonna feel
different or feel
not right but Hughes is ready to make
peace like Liv's biggest critic Rory
McIlroy you know one of the biggest
Sovereign wealth funds in the world
would you rather have them as a partner
or an enemy
um at the end of the day money talks and
you'd rather have them as a partner
those who took Liv's money like Phil
Mickelson are delighted though some
Canadian fans think golfers who stood by
the PGA lost out it felt like they they
stuck with PGA and they they felt like
they got stabbed in the back bottom line
they're touting you know Global growth
and everything else but it's money money
the PGA has always been about the
business of golf but for a time since
the creation of live golf the PGA stood
for something greater in the public eye
a principle against so-called Sports
washing but it seems in the end the
business case won out Eric Sorensen
Global News Toronto
a global news exclusive ahead is a
scientist accused of developing Syria's
chemical weapons program living in
Canada
crews are rushing to rescue ukrainians
stranded after their homes flooded from
a collapsed Dam yesterday
thank you
people waited through swamp streets
carrying their belongings and helping
others with water levels still rising in
some places Rescuers are using boats to
search for the missing hundreds of
thousands of people are without clean
drinking water crops are ruined and the
stage is set for a long-term electricity
shortage a major ecological disaster is
unfolding too thousands of dead fish
washed up on the shores of the reservoir
after it dried up in hours Ukraine and
Russia are blaming each other for the
attack that sent a torrent of water
rushing down the danipro river into
nearby cities and towns
one of the defining parts of Syria's
Civil War has been the Unspeakable
brutality against civilians chemical
weapons were used to kill hundreds of
people over the last decade now global
news has learned a senior scientist
suspected to be behind Syria's chemical
weapons program has been quietly living
in Alberta recently Declassified
documents allege Ahmed haitham al-yafi
helped establish the secret program
working for its Research Center for 20
years he's been deemed a danger to
Canadian Security but evidence suggests
he's lived with his son and
grandchildren in Edmonton for nearly a
decade a warning some of the images of
the aftermath of those chemical weapons
attacks are disturbing Heather urich's
West has this exclusive report
foreign
children struggling for breath the tiny
patients here among the lucky ones
having survived a Syrian
government-sponsored chemical weapons
attack
in August 2013 hundreds convulsed and
suffocated in huta after government
forces fired Rockets loaded with sarin
and a legal nerve agent known to inflict
horrific suffering and pain we know that
Bashar al-assad's regime has used
chemical weapons against Syrian
civilians for many many years and
unfortunately this has been sort of a
forgotten issue in the west so forgotten
it seems Global News has learned an
alleged former senior scientists with
serious chemical weapons program has
been quietly living in Edmonton
of last year yeah residents here knew
little about the allegations surrounding
their elderly neighbor who they say
lived on this quiet street until just a
few months ago very sweet old man but
according to Declassified government
documents obtained by global news
journalist Stuart Bell Ahmed haitham
al-yafi a chemical engineer is alleged
to have worked at the Syrian scientific
study studies and research center from
1974 to 1994. the 2018 Canadian Security
intelligence report says Mr al-yafi was
involved in the startup phase of the
ssrc's pilot plan the purpose of which
was the production of chemical weapons a
subsequent cbsa National screening
division report says al-yafi held high
positions of importance including
project manager and technical director
and later became Syria's Vice minister
of Industry initial thoughts are you
know first of all why are we not
deporting this person and second of all
why are we not considering Prosecuting
this person in a statement to
immigration officials al-yafi denied
ever making chemical weapons since my
PhD was funded by ssrc I had legal
commitments to serve the center for
seven and a half years I found myself
trapped but Canada's immigration system
and a federal court ultimately disagreed
and in 2021 al-yafi's application for
permanent residency was denied the
Edmonton house is up for sale neighbors
say the family hasn't been seen for
several months but with no evidence
al-yafi has been deported the question
remains where is the former Syrian
scientist living now Heather urich's
West Global News Edmonton
[Music]
virgin birth next the crocodile who made
herself pregnant
[Music]
all right we have a fascinating story to
tell you about tonight what experts say
is the first ever instance of a
so-called virgin Birth by a crocodile
according to a new study published in
the Royal Society Journal called biology
letters an 18 year old crocodile laid 14
eggs at a zoo in Costa Rica back in 2018
though none of them hatched a fully
formed fetus was discovered in one of
them the female crocodile lived alone in
an enclosure since the age of two a
genetic analysis confirmed the fetus had
a 99.9 percent DNA match with its mother
confirming there was no father
self-reproduction is rare but has been
documented in some species of birds fish
and other reptiles scientists believe it
happens when certain animals are
endangered or can't find a viable mate
the study suggests the phenomenon might
be more common for crocodiles than
previously realized
and that is global national for this
Wednesday night I'm nitu karcha
tonight's year Canada is Mac to quack
New Brunswick we love seeing your Canada
please keep sending your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks so
much for watching Donna will be back
with you tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
thank you